we talk about the truckers we talk about
pushbacks on vaccines and that the
machine keeps coming and then this is
sort of couched in what the other big
story of the week was this whole week
and started a little bit last week
actually which is that the machine is
moving on joe rogan right there is this
push spotify is going to put uh warnings
before joe rogan's programs because he
spreads misinformation and people are
calling him a bigot and he puts all
these scary people online but what this
really is about is that cnn and
mainstream media the new york times and
washington post and everything else
they're losing control of the narrative
they know that rogan's audience
dwarfs them it's not even close stelter
gets maybe a couple hundred thousand
people and that includes all the people
at the airports and all the people who
are just passively watching or have the
tv on nobody's really watching this like
think about it this way like does anyone
really care about brian stelter right if
he didn't have the chair on the sunday
morning show reliable sources which i
always tell you is the most ironically
named show in television history should
be called unreliable sources and then it
would make a little sense uh if he
didn't have that chair right if they
fired him from that show stelter has no
audience he has no people that would
subscribe to him or watch him or
anything else but the machine puts these
sort of half-baked people in they do
their shows it seems like oh my god he's
on a show called reliable sources and
that's on cnn and it seems very
well the point is that they're losing
control
rogan is bigger than them and they don't
know what to do
so stelter is very concerned about that
the narrative is i want to show all
kinds of opinions
which sounds great but not all opinions
are created equal you think about major
newsrooms like cnn that have health
departments and deaths and operations
that work hard on verified information
october 19. and then you have talk show
stars like joe rogan who just wing it
who make it up as they go along and
because figures like rogan are trusted
by people that don't trust real news
rooms we have attention a problem that's
much bigger than spotify much bigger
than any single platform kate but that's
what there's a heart of this right now
yeah but you're right it is getting at
something bigger that isn't going to be
solved in one joe rogan video or
why should we trust you mr potato head
why should we trust you at this point
you lied about donald trump very fine
people on both sides you lied about
brett kavanaugh being a serial rapist
you lied about the covington kids being
racist you lied about russia collusion
you lied about jesse smilet the list
goes on and on you hid
the hunter biden story while you went
bananas when donald trump jr had lunch
with someone for five minutes on the
upper east side five years ago you
people lie about everything and just
because you have a big newsroom that
means that doesn't mean that that big
newsroom is doing something good that
means that you've got an awful lot of
liars carefully curating the nonsense
that you're pushing out to people but of
course it's not just you brian stelter
much of this comes directly from the
administration and you guys know how
much i like talking about jen saki so
we've got a gen sake video and you know
because everyone these days is putting
warnings content warnings out on stuff
we thought guys maybe we should put a
content warning every time we show a
video from saki because she's always
lying and spreading misinformation and
disinformation there you go content
advisory warning what you're about to
see
is [ __ ] take a look last week the
surgeon general also was asked on msnbc
about joe rogan's vaccine comments
on spotify and he said that tech
companies have an important role to play
in stopping misinformation because the
uh they are the predominant places where
misinformation spreads does the white
house and the administration think this
is a satisfactory step our hope is that
all major tech platforms and all major
news sources for that matter be
responsible and be vigilant to ensure
the american people have access to
accurate information on something as
significant as covid19 that certainly
includes spotify so this disclaimer it's
a positive step but we want every
platform to continue doing more to call
out misinformants and disinformation
while also uplifting accurate
information
oh jen oh jen
i don't like you jen but i'm trying to
be nice this morning um first off nobody
should care what the white house thinks
about what a private company does okay
it's irrelevant well it should be
irrelevant
and this is how they push this is how
they get as close as they can to
violating the first amendment without
quite violating the first amendment and
you all know about this right we had the
surgeon general who came out and said
you know that the government should look
into a little bit more we should kind of
be thinking about misinformation when it
comes to joe rogan's podcast it's like
we're not going to pass a law saying he
can't say stuff but we're going to just
think about it and then and then think
about it this way you're joe rogan right
you're sitting at home you're joe rogan
you're eating your elk you're working
out you're doing your thing you're
sitting there with the scary wolf all of
the stuff and then you open up twitter
and you see that the surgeon general is
thinking about you and you might just as
an individual you might go ah maybe i
won't do that stuff so there's a certain
pressure that they can apply that is
as close to violating the first
amendment as they possibly could and we
know of course we've shown you the video
many times a few months back where saki
said that the white house flags posts
for facebook so if you're the guy at
facebook and you're sitting there at
your desk and you're doing your thing
and you're good and you're a diversity
hire and you're just a nice diversity
hire and you're trans and you're black
and you're you have one eye and whatever
it is but you're a good worker uh you
know and all that stuff and then you get
a message from the white house and they
say
you know we'd really like you to flag
this thing well you're going to do it
because you're a good diversity hire and
you're going to do what you're told
because that's what a good american
citizen does
this would be an instance of a company
in this case facebook's a public company
but getting pressure from the government
to impede on speech we got a big problem
here
so what are we going to do about this
problem i think we just got to keep
pushing we all got to find our inner
canadian truck driver right now because
saki rogan's allowed to talk about what
he wants to talk about and stealther
just because you got a big newsroom
doesn't mean it's doing anything good
and
i got nothing better to do than stop you
guys so we're just going to keep moving
on that